hundreds of thousands of Quebec students
are on strike today they're protesting
against tuition fee increases a
student's say that amounts to a
declaration of war
massive student-led protests of left
Montreal and turmoil for much of 2012
the upheaval caused by the protests and
the government's heavy-handed reactions
to them have divided Quebec society
while mostly peaceful some demonstrators
resorted to vandalism and blocked access
to bridges and schools protesters were
also met with violence from riot police
and accusations of brutality became a
nightly occurrence desperate to restore
order the Liberal government of Quebec
passed the emergency law bill 78 which
has effectively ended the larger
protests hailed as a pragmatic solution
by supporters who say it has rescued the
city from anarchy critics such as the
United Nations Human Rights Council have
condemned Bill 78 as an egregious
violation of free expression gabrielado
Dubois spokesperson for the largest and
most radical of Quebec student unions
explained a recent TV how a tuition hike
of about 50 cents per day became the
flashpoint of such broad-based civil
unrest the universities of Quebec are
they cheaper in Canada and the cheaper
in North America also and in Quebec
that's something that we are very proud
of it's because of those low tuition
fees that we have the most accessible
post-secondary education system despite
the lowest tuition costs in North
America Quebec also boasts some of the
lowest attendance rates representatives
of the free market Montreal economic
Institute take great exception to the
protesters depiction of the conflict as
class war Quebec government and that is
connect taxpayers pay anywhere between
say ninety to ninety two percent of you
know the current costs of their studies
but what the protesters are saying is
that they want Quebec taxpayers to pay
for all the cost of all of their studies
Quebec student unions are modeled after
labor unions and they responded to the
government's tuition hike with a student
strike of all universities people have
to understand that what we're doing in
Quebec is a strike
not a boycott the decision to go on
strike is not taking individual it taken
collectively by a General Assembly if
you're a student you are automatically a
member
a few student associations so when the
decision to go on strike taken the
strike applies to everyone
far from enjoying universal support the
General Assembly's compelled many non
striking students into what they called
solidarity by force
the problem with General Assembly's some
students couldn't be there Concordia
University for example five hundred
students put ten thousand students on
strike it was not always a referendum at
large it was not secret ballot so you
really have an issue of democracy right
there obviously students want to go to
their classes they have been accepted in
different programs for the new year
after they need to finish the semesters
and they don't have time for protesting
in Canada the the right to strike is a
privilege reserved to workers well on
the lawsuit and we want student that
pays for his education
it's a service he doesn't have to follow
the decision of the majority far from
resolving the conflict the strikers saw
the injunction as an escalation all the
students decided to fill up injunctions
in front of the court to break the
strike mandates and to force the did the
cop to go back to class so then they had
no choice but to hold picket lines in
front of the colleges and universities
to say well we have taken a collective
decision and we have to expect it
collectively and the academic
consequences of the strike they will be
assumed collectively also after the
strike the strike penalizes everyone
equally I have no problem that people
want to boycott classes but they cannot
enforce the decision by blocking the
access to everybody because they're the
majority bill Watson a professor of
Montreal's McGill University is critical
of some of the tactics of the student
movement people were gathering in their
thousands
and then marching and more or less
random order on different routes every
night they've gathered in support from
all sorts of people with all sorts of
grievances people from the Occupy
movement people from the
anti-globalization movement people from
a more traditional labor union posture
even though it's in a sense a local
fight against tuition hike it's also a
broader fight against the privatization
of public services and against austerity
like measures the anarcho Panda is the
alter ego of a junior college philosophy
professor who's taken an
national peacekeeping role in the
student strike PNR cope and spends a lot
of his I assume paid time because he's
not given his classes his classes have
been suspended but his pay has not been
suspended trying to bring police and
opponents of the protests and the
protesters into a better state of mind
it's the kind of symbol that truly
disturbs the police officers who are
used to being very rough to the
protesters and when you see this huge
panda in front of you it's kind of
disturbing because he's there with his
big smile wanting to hug all the police
the students were victims of violence
from the police fairly early on as a
teacher and somebody that cares for
students I started looking for ways to
try to help the students with that when
the right police shows up I try to be
there in the front line and to interact
with them they have a very strict
behavioral protocol they're not allowed
to be human essentially they're not
allowed to talk to you they're not
allowed to look at you in the eye
they're just there to be the sort of
brute force of the system by talking to
them and by interacting with them I try
to remind them that they are people too
and that they will be judged both
legally and by their own conscience
but not all demonstrators were as
pacifistic as the anarcho panda
incidents like the smoke bomb attack in
the underground subway system and the
vandalization of the montreal economic
Institute's downtown offices marred the
movements preferred image of nonviolent
civil disobedience as protests grew
larger and more disruptive and as
conflicts with police grew more violent
the government of Quebec passed bill 78
an emergency law which suspended the
university term essentially locking out
the strikers it also banned masks during
protests introduced huge fines on
protest organizers and demanded prior
notice of protest routes you've
essentially got traffic block in
unpredictable ways every night and
you're running a city other people are
trying to get on with their lives it's
not unreasonable to require protests of
more than 50 people to tell the police 8
hours in advance that's all and those
you have to give look we're gonna gather
here and we're gonna go from here to
there and for us it's a it's a totally
unacceptable measures now the police
officers will be able to say that you
can protest but not there and you have
to go in the field and we want to put
this in downtown no you will protest in
the neighborhood away from everyone
where you are seen by no one
and
you disturb nothing the idea was to
disrupt it was very effective in
disrupting but I think as civilized
society has the right to regulate this
kind of thing and say look people who
are not interested in this issue who
don't in fact agree with you do have the
right to conduct their lives in the
normal way that they see fit but in the
democratic society you should be able to
protest where you want and to express
yourself where you want and when you
want and that's a lot more important
than any minor economic disturbance of a
few hours in any downtown Canadian
Constitution a lawyer Julius gray a
supporter of the student protests
explains the severe civil liabilities of
bill 78 there could be a class action by
some person that comes in and says I'm a
student I wanted to go to my classes and
I lost $3,000 and if there's 10,000 of
them civil liability could ruin a
student for the rest of his life
anyone who lost the entry of a education
institution can receive a fine of about
$10,000 per person if you are a local
Student Association you can go up to
$50,000 and if you are a national for
union representative like me you can
have up to a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per day there was some
justification in order to increase the
amount of those fines because incentive
matters and if you have a particular
action which is blocking access to
colleges blocking bridges so that people
cannot move freely violating the
freedoms of other people and this
particular course of action is costing
you $1,500
you're not gonna react the same way as
if it's costing you a quarter of a
million this law will apply only for one
year and we are actually in front of the
court to make this law declared
unconstitutional the Association of
lawyers association of judges everyone
I'm pretty sure we will win but it's
gonna be so long and when we will win
the law will no longer be applied and
the government will have succeeded in
going over the institutions that are
here protect civil liberties in the
civil right it is probably a law that
was not necessary and so in that sense
it's maybe a case of government
over regulation the argument against
bill 78 is that most of the powers that
one talks about already in the criminal
code I don't see any reason to pass a
law that forbids riots I mean riots are
prohibited in the Criminal Code of
Canada I don't see any advantage on the
other hand the civil liability the
delegation of powers and the Prevention
of spontaneous demonstrations are
serious serious invasions of civil
liberties the 78 was a panic move to
kill the mobilization but in fact it's
at the exact opposite that effect since
bill 78 we have seen hundreds of
thousands of citizens students citizens
each night going out with their pots and
pans banging on them to show their
disapproval this bill is a direct threat
to certain rights that all citizens have
not only students to express their
opinion and to freely assemble Quebec
universities are scheduled to reopen for
class in August and a Supreme Court
decision on the constitutionality of
bill 78 is likely several months away
though the nightly protests have
continued in much smaller numbers the
student unions are planning another
massive protest for August 22nd where
hundreds of thousands are expected to
march through Montreal it remains
difficult to judge bill 78 as a
reasonable intervention for the public
good or a draconian law imposed by a
panicking government mass movements like
the Tea Party the Arab Spring and the
Occupy movement suggest a new paradigm
of civil disobedience in the global
zeitgeist but the conflict in Quebec
presents a dilemma that has yet to be
solved where is the line between freely
expressing dissent and depriving other
people of their liberties